Since I came here they always say
that since it is the time of the Latino because
there is going to be a lot of interest in Latino
and despite that things do not change
much so Hollywood has always been
like a place of childish melancholy
for all of us because  We have
grown up watching movies
about cities and conflicts that will not be
far away, but our own cinema appears in our memory
,
it's called, the circulation is
greater,
but when a movie is made in
any movie in Mexico,
I think of Chilango, I dream of Chilango.
I think that in my bad I don't speak Spanish I don't
speak English but my
English also only just
working massacred it even more with
Mexican chilango expressions and so on so there is
a part that is there all the
time I always want to talk about my country
I don't want to  talk about something else that
I always want to tell about a Mexico that I
see there is always something that I say now I am going
to talk about this part of Mexico or
this place or this aspect of my
own culture in any movie
filmed a filmed has always been like this
I recognized my country thanks to watching the
movies my mission to recognize the
face of my country my city my
needs my desires and  my
desires I know very Mexican of course very
Mexican because of all my contacts
but my nation is Spanish in the
language that a Castilian speaks in Spain
due to problems of nationalism
but most of us who speak it
on this side of the
Atlantic say Spanish
in Latin
In this way we are giving this
human encouragement and I like being able to
participate not only in the
conversation in my country but also in
the world convention because Mexico is
part of the world and I think that is where
we also have to talk because it
already affects us all  We are not isolated,
nor are we a foreign country, nor are we an island
of getting to know other cultures, other
places, cinema is very important,
but there is a kind of  cinema or whatever
you want to say that sometimes if it has
to be very particularly made in
Latin America I realized that a
much more vibrant world than a model and a
genre know
we are going to love
to like to want to learn to do
say thank god we are
different